it's so it's good to remember that Yale
is a competitive place and as I
surprise when there was a sheaf of hand
rid of typed notes pulled out to the
side of me whereas I thought I would
speak somewhat extemporaneously and of
course to my surprise I'm seated between
two presidents
now you're making fun of us you'll pay
for that
so my background is engineering and I
went to what's now the School of
Engineering applied science and I have
to say that some of the comments made
earlier don't seem to necessarily apply
as much in engineering applied science I
was in the school from about nineteen
eighty to nineteen eighty four and in
engineering at least you tend to be
organized with research professors you
tend to see your fellow classmates or
research group members on a daily basis
in a lab or perhaps in preparing a lab
for students for teaching and there's
just a lot of daily interaction with
everybody so we're not kind of loan
asteroids wandering around the Yale
universe we are really to collect a
family and that that family was very
very important to me in terms of
learning how to study learning how to do
research and and that's really what I
think for me graduate school is all
about was kind of taking that next step
to teaching myself since then I was a
faculty member at Columbia I went to
work for the government for a while I
ran a couple of businesses i'm back in a
university environment that i was trying
to think what is special about the yale
graduate school and i started getting
worried because actually in the school
of engineering applied science we have
fairly at that time had fairly little
interaction with the graduate school I
remember coming in I remember depositing
my thesis and in between maybe a few
trips to hgs to visit some friends but
not too much in between but inside the
engineering school was a very strong
supportive environment which I really
appreciate and I was trying to think
what what was different about Yale
compared to my time at Columbia with my
students or my time at Dartmouth now or
my time in other endeavors and one of
the things that I thought about was
really special about Yale is that I
found you out to be a nurturing
environment rather
more Darwinian environment and what I
mean is that at Columbia for example I
don't mean to pick on Columbia but at
Columbia they would admit a lot of
graduate students in engineering of
course I'm talking about and then after
a year or so between rigorous coursework
and a very difficult examination they
would really weed out well that's
probably the wrong term they would
probably ask about half those students
to leave I don't remember the exact
statistics but it was a very large
fraction and their philosophy was well
you know if we put these students to
these tests and they survive they must
be really good where is it yet I found a
different environment which was that
over the course of the first year the
professor's took note of where your
areas of strengths were and where your
areas of weakness were and then after a
year they kind of sit down and talk with
you and try to strengthen those areas
where your week to try to make you kind
of strong across a wide range of areas
sometimes you can prescribing courses
you need to take that you didn't think
you had to take and so they're kind of
nurturing environment something that I
took with me beyond Yale of course I
tried to apply it amongst my own
graduate research group at Columbia but
also even going to a Jet Propulsion lab
and then in business I found that it
really is a very valuable skill to be
very careful about who you hire but once
they're in the door really try to
nurture them and find out what their
true skill sets are what they're good at
if they don't quite succeeding in the
first thing that you assign them to
maybe try to find something else now i'm
not that liberal I've certainly fired my
fair share of employees that didn't work
out but I think it's really worth while
to really take the time to try to find
out what people are good at and to put
them in the right position I think that
really counts a lot and so this I think
is really the strength that stands out
of my mind
my experience of the i'll graduate
school thank you